so i just finished watching david
lowry's the green knight and this ending
had me feel like my head was chopped off
with his hand but he's hate all but my
decapitated head aside i took some time
to reflect on sir gawain's journey and
have pieced together what that tragic
ending means as well as some of the
film's biggest
unanswered questions like what is the
fox who is the green knight
and how come deb patel hasn't won an
oscar yet so join me on this journey as
we explore this tragic tale
and if you like what you're hearing be
sure to like and subscribe i come out
with all sorts of videos on film theory
analysis
and deep dives the green knight starts
ominously with our lead sir
wayne sitting on the throne as king he
is the nephew of king arthur yes
that king arthur of camelot and since
arthur has no heir
gawain is next in line to the throne but
this introduction foreshadows the film's
tragic end as gawain bursts into flames
just like his kingdom will under his
rule
but we'll get to that in a bit it's
christmas and gawain at night of the
round table has spent the previous night
at the brothel indulging in women and
drink he is basically the opposite of
what a noble knight should be
the question then becomes when gawain
ultimately embarks on his quest
will he change will he become a better
man and night worthy of the round table
we meet gawain's mother morgan le faye
who in the poem the story is based off
is arthur's half-sister in some versions
of this tale morgan is an antagonist to
arthur wanting to use serp his throne
and that's one interpretation
of the events that are about to
transpire note here that morgan is also
upset
that her son was out at the brothel
instead of at church we'll later find
out that it was morgan a sorceress
trained under merlin who we see briefly
in the film
that summoned the green knight in the
first place the movie never explains why
she does this
was it to test her son sending him on
this quest to make him a better man
or was it all a ploy for her to
eventually get her son
on the throne on christmas the king
queen guinevere and the knights of the
round table
celebrate when gawain is brought to sit
alongside the king
he asks wayne to tell him a mighty tale
to which he responds he has
none to tell that's because gawain is an
unproven knight but this is soon to be
rectified when the celebration is
interrupted by the green knight
holding a note sealed in green wax the
same note we see going's mother writing
the green knight challenges one who is
of bold blood and honor to strike him
down
and if successful will have one year to
travel to the green chapel
return his axe and be struck down in
return but the king tells gawain who's
up for the challenge
don't worry it's all a game or is it as
going accepts the challenge he's
surprised when instead of fighting the
green knight merely kneels and presents
his neck to be cut
clean off there's no honor in this and
perhaps this could be interpreted as
gawain's first
nightly test traditionally the medieval
code of knighthood and chivalry held
five virtues among all else this is why
the knights of the round were a
five-pointed star a reminder of these
virtues
as gwen embarks on his quest he will be
tested on these five virtues
they are generosity chastity friendship
courtesy and piety and let me tell you
he fails miserably the first virtue test
gawain encounters on his journey is
generosity as he passes an abandoned
battlefield he uncovers a young
scavenger who has lost his two brothers
gawain doesn't give the boy so much as a
hey i'm sorry for your loss not to
mention the boy has to practically beg
for payment when he gives going
directions to the green chapel and even
when going does give him something it's
only a single coin
gawain fails this test the second virtue
is courtesy he stumbles into a
stranger's home and falls asleep on
their bed
very courteous he'll later be awoken by
the lady of the house winifred who asks
for his help in retrieving her head from
the bottom of a pawn
instead of doing so out of courtesy he
asks what he'll get in return only to be
chastised by her gawain is also
discourteous when he breaks the deal he
has with joel edgarton's character the
lord the deal states that
everything the lord earns on his hunt
will be given to gawain and everything
gawain earns in the house will be given
to the lord
gawain fails to tell the lord that he
was given a magical green sash by the
lady of the house
a sash that will protect him from a
killing blow the lady here is also
played by the same actress alicia
vickender who plays
essel gawain's peasant love interest it
just goes to show that gawain can't be
taken as a reliable narrator and as such
everything we see him go through might
not be what it seems
we see him hallucinate several times in
the film like when he sees his own dead
body
or after eating poisonous mushrooms that
means things like the
fox and the giants may never have been
real in the first place
i did enjoy the giant scene and how gwen
asked one of them for a lift across the
valley that would have been the easy and
unheroic way of achieving his journey
which is why the fox tells the giants to
screw off
foxes are often seen as tricksters
however in the celtic belief system they
are also seen as spirit guides and
symbols of the afterlife which is what i
interpret this version as being
there are several images in the film
which depict a human head on a fox's
body which could mean the fox is a
manifestation
of gawain's inner desire to do well on
his quest the fox also ties directly
into the third chivalric virtue
friendship at first gawain throws rocks
at the fox but the two
soon become friends it's at the end
however when the friendship is broken as
gawain scares off the fox who tries to
ward him away from
death the fourth virtue everyone's
favorite is chastity
as a guest in the lord's manner near the
end of his journey he falls prey to the
lady of the house's seduction and when
he finally climaxes she tells him he's
no knight
i should also bring up this weird blind
lady here who is seen yet never says a
word during this entire sequence
the only other person to wear a
blindfold like this is gawain's
enchantress mother
morgan this is likely her watching over
her son
on this journey the final virtue is
piety we've seen how gawain isn't
religious in the slightest preferring to
spend christmas eve at the brothel
going's actions do not stem from a
desire to please god or the king they
stem from a desire to please himself
he puts himself before others and as
such fails this virtue
harnessing these five virtues makes one
honorable and in the world of king
arthur one's worth was judged by one's
honor this leads us to the moral lesson
of the green knight which one of the a24
trailers states is
in this tale lies a moral lesson that
echoes through time
to make honor our guiding light
through the darkest of our journeys so
gwen fails these five tests but makes
his way to the green chapel to confront
the green knight in one
final test will gawain have the courage
to be struck down by the green knight
and honor his deal with this magical
entity
the answer no and yes at first galway
flinches as the green knight swings his
axe and ultimately going
runs away a coward we then see what his
life would be like should he return back
home
he'll become king and he accepts
knighthood even though we've just seen
him be nothing but
undeserving of it he'll take essels and
his child and because essel isn't noble
will discard essel to live the rest of
the days without him and their child
paying her money for her quote-unquote
services as he grows older he'll watch
his son die in battle then return home
having
[ __ ] flung at him like joffrey in game
of thrones he is an unloved leader this
ultimately ends with an attack on the
castle where he takes off his green sash
the thing that protects him
accepting his fate and dying with
neither honor nor
nobility but just as that's about to
happen we're transported right back when
gawain is about to get his head chopped
off
it's almost as if he has seen his life
or should i say future life
flash before his eyes instead of running
this time he takes off the sash
and accepts his fate he would rather die
an honorable person then live out a
dishonorable life filled with pain
misery grief and death the green knight
tells him
well done my brave knight he has finally
become that night and maybe that's what
his mother who conjured the green knight
in the first place
wanted from her son to turn him into an
honorable man so the ending can be
interpreted one of three ways
one gawain flees like a coward to become
king and lead his kingdom to ruin two
gawain is beheaded and dies an honorable
man
or three gawain chooses to die but is
spared by the green knight to go back
home
and change the course of his ways
remember we never actually see the green
knight behead him
and his final line off with your head i
interpret it as being delivered more
jokingly
so who is the green knight winifred says
it's someone he knows which ties
directly into the theory he was conjured
by his mother there are never
any signs that his mother wants to kill
him this is why i happen to subscribe to
the third interpretation that this was
all a ploy by his mother to smarten
going
up to better prepare him for his future
as king i see him coming back home and
having learned from the heir of his ways
become a different king than the one we
saw depicted in the film's final moments
a king with honor and integrity a brave
knight as the green knight called him
but that's the beauty of this
open-endedness it's open to
interpretation
as stated in one of the a24 trailers
scholars believe the green knight's
character also symbolizes a respect for
nature
the unknown and death this hearkens back
to the speech the lady gives gawain
about why the green knight is green and
i want to hear what you thought of the
green knight
do you have a different interpretation i
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone remember to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you